let's talk about skill based matchmaking
in call of duty it's a
very controversial topic right now a lot
of streamers are telling you
that you do not like sbmm and we're here
to dig into
what skill-based matchmaking is why you
probably feel the way you do
and even what some experts have to say
about it i'm sure that you have a lot of
thoughts on this
so make sure to hop into the chat below
and let us know what you think did we
get things right did we get things wrong
while you're at it give us the old
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get into it
alright so what is skill based
matchmaking skill based matchmaking is a
multiplayer system designed to basically
place you with people of the same skill
level
and there are a lot of ways that it can
go wrong as call of duty players have
been noticing
spmm can take into account a lot of
things about you
like your kill death ratio your win loss
ratio your ping
how you perform in groups vs solo and
even how often you quit for the night
after losing matches
it feeds into other ideas like ranked
which is a visual measure of how good
you are
and engagement which is how often you
play and speaking of engagement we've
been hearing a lot of call of duty
streamers say they've been falling off
richie why do you think that streamers
are the most vocal about skill based
matchmaking
in general they're the most vocal
because they're the the better of the
players they they rank high in
good lobbies and they get affected most
by skill-based matchmaking and cheating
a lot so they're they're the vocal ones
because uh
for those reasons and also it's it's a
lot of people's
job on youtube to talk about it or job
to stream it on on twitch
and it's becoming very difficult to play
a game that's turning their back on them
in terms of
all these problems but for the average
joe
like maybe me i'm not in a diamond lobby
very much
in the middle of the pack somewhere and
below it may not seem like a big problem
because
the average joe plays in in
medium skilled lobbies with medium
skilled players
that the hackers just buzz right over
then go to the top ranked diamond
lobbies
i'm personally somewhere in the middle
and i get cheaters sometimes
um for me it's fortunately we can turn
off cross uh
cross play i'm not on pc i'm on
playstation 5 but
even then there are contraptions that
make uh
your controller aimbot people so i still
feel the wrath
in a regular decently skilled lobby
but on the higher end of things they're
feeling them
they're feeling all those hackers and
cheaters every match
it seems and that's really affecting the
way they play
you know their fan base their love of
the game it's all sort of going downhill
what are some of the things that make
streaming more challenging with skill
based matchmaking kind of cheat cheaters
aside because they are a problem
it's it's still hard in some ways
because you want to have a a nice stream
for your audience especially
people on uh or or make good content on
youtube i follow a lot of people like
drifter or exclusive ace who like to
break down things but also stream for
their audience it's a great way to
engage fans and even get to play with
them it's already hard in these lobbies
because they're they're
sweaty enough playing in these diamond
rank lobbies and
uh that's where the lower end of things
is totally different if you're
matchmaking with people of less skill
you can you know
you're just you can make more mistakes
and it's more forgiving
but in the higher ranked lobbies you
can't make a single mistake otherwise
you're screwed
it's hard to just entertain people and
do your job
if it revolves around call of duty it's
it's not so
i don't want to say relaxed but it's not
it can it can
it can drop in in the fun level you know
like you want to have a fun
casual stream for your fans and it's not
always the case in fact
lately it's never the case anymore a lot
of people are starting to slowly fall
off because of it too
my gameplay experience has gone down the
tubes and
i'm just wanting to play warzone without
someone beaming me across the map
because they have
aimbot i want to know that if some so
that's how skill-based matchmaking has
affected
the people we like to watch and us as
the casual player
but aaron it sounds like you've dug into
some more stats and studies about
skill-based matchmaking and
how it works you want to talk about that
oh man it's it's a pretty deep rabbit
hole
but uh i went and i looked up some
studies on skill-based matchmaking
particularly those by an individual
named josh menke who's worked on
call of duty and halo he's done a lot of
gdc talks on halo this is from more the
developer side of things and i'm
paraphrasing this skill based
matchmaking
from a developer perspective seems to be
more about perception
perception of fairness and the argument
is that
skill-based matchmaking is good for
players as long as
you can control how it's implemented so
you don't want these
massive skill gaps and there's two kinds
of skill gaps there's the
individual skill gap and there's a team
skill gap and one of them is more
important i'll get into that
in a second skill based matchmaking is
actually in a lot of games and you don't
know it so for example he was saying
that in halo 2
the difference between casual and ranked
was just that ranked
told you what your rank was and that's
relevant because right now
i think for the first time warzone
players because of an external website
are finally able to see
what their actual rank is in the game
but what that says is that
your perception of fairness basically
comes from what the game
tells you is the game telling you what
lobbies you're in
or is it not if it's not telling you
what lobbies you're in
then it's there's a danger that players
can think that they can't win a match
now it's possible
that skill-based matchmaking is being
done poorly
there's a lot of mechanics in games like
or movies too like sound
or you know your gamepad controlling a
game that are invisible
unless they're done really well or
they're done really poorly but like
somewhere in the middle they kind of
disappear
and skill miss matchmaking is the same
thing when it's done well
you probably won't notice it that much
and um
but when it's done poorly you'll notice
it a lot all right so so let's go back
to
the idea of the skill gap and that you
can't win one study that they looked at
in halo 5 was whether players actually
leave when they think they can't win
because of skill based matchmaking
and what they said was that your
personal skill gap
like when you come around a corner in a
1v1 fight
is a little bit less important than the
the team one which kind of makes sense
right like if you're on a team that's
just getting absolutely stomped you're
gonna leave for the night
so there's a little bit more wiggle room
for for like
one verse one fights and and people
won't leave they won't rage quit a game
so much
if if the skill based matchmaking isn't
quite as good in that regard but people
still want a good
competitive match they don't necessarily
want really really really tight
skill-based matchmaking where they have
that 1-1 kd because that's not fun to
kill trade right like every time you
come around a corner if it's a 50-50
shot
that's not particularly fun so you know
they quantify this and they want like a
they want like a kind of a looser skill
based matchmaking games
so there's a pretty wide range of people
you come around a corner and fight on a
1v1
now that's very different when it comes
to team based matchmaking
in one specific study on halo 5 they
said that a team of four
can scare off up to 20 people per hour
well like i'm talking about people who
just say screw it i'm gonna lose no
matter what against this team
and they don't just quit the game they
quit for the entire night
so different games handle skill based
matchmaking with teams a little bit
differently
overwatch for example won't allow the
highest skilled players
to uh to match up with their friends
because if the highest skilled players
team up with their other friends who are
in the highest skill tier
they'll stomp everybody and everybody
will have a miserable time and quit
so kind of going back to what you were
saying originally with with youtubers
they they are
they tend to be in that really high
skill tier and the danger is actually
that if you
if you let them squat up and you don't
have a decent skill based matchmaking
system
it's like the halo 5 scenario right they
can actually legitimately scare off
you know in halo 5 20 players per hour
who just will not play that game anymore
because they think they can't win
so yeah like sort of in summary
skill-based matchmaking
it's when it's done well it's invisible
and when it's done well there's like a
very wide range
so you still have a you know pretty
decent chance of coming around a corner
on
on players of various skills and when
it's too tight
and you come around a corner of the same
skill every time you just kill trade and
it's not fun
but it gets way bad with with team-based
matchmaking which is
something that i think you know a lot of
online shooters have trouble with
it's all about how skill-based
matchmaking is implemented and players
won't necessarily rage quit even though
they say they're going to
unless it gets really bad which is
probably why
call of duty and activision despite how
vocal people are about it
we'll probably keep it in their game and
not get rid of it unless something
really
bad happens activision's skill-based
matchmaking
for the last few years has been pretty
strict that's which is the issue here
but they've also like i'm not sure if
you've heard that they
they they can take your information for
you know all these websites that popped
up that show
players skill and you can even you were
even able to check
in your lobby that you're in the skills
of all these players
and their rank and stuff like that
that's why i kept calling them diamond
lobbies there are gold lobbies bronze
and so on
but these these websites were shut down
almost overnight because activision put
a big blanket over all those stats
and returned them back to their private
settings
which which makes it harder for people
to zoom in on cheaters and see oh i have
three
hackers in my lobby blatant hackers that
are level like
you know a million and have a thousand
kills a night
uh so that's another issue that
activision sort of
hasn't really dealt with aside from just
putting a wet blanket over the issue and
sort of ignoring the problem hopefully
they're fixing the issue but
a lot of these helpful websites we're
just taking down overnight
and that's really fascinating because
what you're saying
is exactly what these studies were
saying which is that it's about
perception
if people think a game is unfair a lot
of it becomes because the game is not
communicating things like they're ranked
to them
and by activision taking away that
information that means that players are
going to perceive
matches as more unfair because they have
less information
so that's exactly what this guy was
talking about he was saying
you need to tell players where they're
at or they're going to just assume it's
unfair
or if they get killed it's because of
bad skill based matchmaking
what has been your experience with skill
based matchmaking we really want to know
how
it affects you so make sure to hop in
the comments below and speak up we're
covering a lot more call of duty
including a new zombies map called
firebase z coming up soon
so make sure to head on over to gamespot
and watch all of our other videos on
call of duty
thanks for watching
[Music]
you